l'autre coup de théâtre judiciaire de la
journée concerne l affaire du sang
contaminé les docteurs alain égard et à
devait-il être jugé pour empoisonnement
devant une cour d'assises
jusqu'à maintenant vous le savez la
justice avait toujours répondu non et
bien cet après-midi devant la cour de
cassation l'avocat général a estimé lui
que les deux médecins auraient dû être
jugés pour empoisonnement dominique
verdeilhan la liste des victimes
la liste aussi des plaignants qui depuis
des années demandent que leur dossier
aille devant les assises dans la salle
quelques unes sont là pour ce dernier
combat juridique et dans l'après-midi
une surprise l'avocat général jean
perfetti se range à leurs côtés ils
prônent l'empoisonnement il évoque une
correctionnalisation douteuses et
demande pour le respect de l'ordre
public
le renvoi devant une cour d'assises des
docteur garetta et alain c'était un
travail très long un combat très long et
je crois qu'on est entendu que la
qualification d'empoisonnement n'était
pas une qualification qui étaient jetés
comme ça en l'air c'est une
qualification qui juridiquement à des
bases et qui est maintenant défendu par
la cour de cassation
dans cette affaire le parquet n'a jamais
diligenter une enquête
on la demande depuis neuf ans alors on a
toujours eu l'impression
café
un blocage sur cette affaire peut-être
que
qu'elle était trop près des politiques
assurément pour les victimes c'est ce
soir une victoire mais il leur faudra
attendre mercredi prochain après midi
date à laquelle la cour de cassation
rendra son arrêt en dépend le sort
judiciaire des docteur garetta et alain
mais cet arrêt aura également une
conséquence sur la suite à donner à 25
plaintes 25 plainte pour empoisonnement
actuellement instruites par la justice
et visant les trois anciens ministres et
les membres de leurs cabinets mercredi
prochain la justice pourrait donc
relancer la faire neuf ans après les
faits